wer viele fragen sich jetzt auch wie
geht's weiter wo kann ich überhaupt noch
in urlaub fahren wir wollen einen einmal
gemeinsam frank einen blick auf europa
werfen auf die zahlen von europa wie es
da aussieht denn da kann man zumindest
sagen sie deutschland ja vergleichsweise
ganz gut aus wir sehen hier die karte
eingeblendet und yahoo sind die gebiete
in denen der wert über 50 liegt also der
siebten tages wert pro 100000 einwohner
wir sehen das ist nahezu in ganz europa
erreicht wir sehen nur noch einzelne
ausnahmen serbien mit 24 schweden mit 38
ansonsten aber alles rot daher die frage
an dich frank wo können wir überhaupt
noch in urlaub fahren
also wir haben uns zur schlau gemacht
und haben alle reiseexperten in der
redaktion auch extern haben die köpfe
zusammengesteckt und wir haben
herausgefunden
ich nenne jetzt mal wirklich 10 ziel die
halt gehen zypern wird noch empfohlen
costa rica hat man nicht so auf der uhr
aber auch das geht so schälen wissen wir
es beliebt auch gerade bei ihm fern
touristen malediven griechenland
natürlich nummer 1 das heißt in
griechenland ist alles noch möglich da
gibt es zurzeit gar keine
einreisebeschränkungen italien kanal
sind wieder geöffnet madeira und auch
namibia das sind aber wirklich nur noch
sehr wenige länder
und das zeigt natürlich doch auch wie
bedrohlich auch die situation rund um
ist